salut georges cette émission ça devient
comme tournez manège
alors soit les couples célèbres alors un
soir tu vas chez silvia bourdon et tu
rencontres sylvia oui tu sais j'ai
toujours bible des [ __ ]
ouais je
je suis un amoureux des plus complets je
crois que je me suis tapé toutes des
[ __ ] de paris depuis que j'y suis je
suis arrivé à paris où l'avait jamais
rencontrée à n'ont jamais jamais est ce
qu est ce qui m'a plus dans l tuer elle
a un petit minois d'haïti touchés et
c'est excitant quoi à quand quand tu
vois ce petit enfant de choeur et qui
dit qu'il va peut-être dessus c'est tout
à l'heure et et ça c'est formidable
et puis bon je vais proposer mille
balles compter le prix où ils étaient un
peu radin sur les boulevards
non c'était uniquement pour pour
déjeuner ou dîner par d'autres produits
peuvent être à sa table j'étais autant
il m'a rien donné du coup mais comment
ça s'est passé alors tu as su tout de
suite que c'était un grand amour ou tu
t'es comment ça s'est passé
tu sais
elle est rentrée chez moi ouais et puis
j'ai vu qu'elle était un petit peu
pouvaient quand même
alors je me suis dit mme attias qui va
en profiter
une italie j'ai un grand appartement
pour moi tout ça le machin tu
t'installes qui fait la cuisine tous à 8
voix puis on est là depuis depuis ce
moment là et finalement finalement tu
vois et elle a commencé à faire la [ __ ]
candide aux enfants de dieu et il était
sauvé par le diable de la compétition en
battant jeu par rapport aux autres
produits comme le dit dans la suite de
l'histoire et vous ayez quand même temps
que cet ensemble ça va faire trois ans
paraît quand même ça c'est rien ne vous
trompez pas rien vous êtes trop beau si
je me trompe mais elle me dit elle a le
droit à une rue quand je n'ose pas
d'affaires pendantes où je dois judy à
yop ce mec là tu te tu te fais tu sais
dans un coin il sera content ça va
m'aider dans mes affaires voilà
et elle marche puis ça y est et
effectivement ça m'aide
vous êtes un couple moderne je sais pas
on sait rester longtemps ensemble mais
ça m'excite un peu moi il va de d'avoir
une famille une vraie plus de bain et
puis tu sais on est mieux servie par des
professionnels c'est ce qui faire appel
à des pros un comme toi tu as des noirs
à réparer et tu fais appel à un plombier
tu veux un vrai or c'est dur à trouver
les plombiers oui c'est dur parce que je
vois bien leur boulot et dans les buts
aussi d'ailleurs
enfin il ya des vrais ya val d'oise elle
c'est une vraie [ __ ] c'est tout et
c'est bien tu le connaissais avant toi
tu connais sert à tirer quand même
regretter ce thème as tu détestais
complètement c'est l'aspect d'une ville
déjà touchée que j'ai accepté de
rencontrer
bon je suis également il n'était ce pas
une tête dans son état normal
ouais alors c'est comment si tu veux
jeter coller avec une manette depuis 30
ans ah ouais et ses flingues et si
celui-ci d'ailleurs aux barbituriques
donc c'est évident que tu n'aies l'aide
que tu calcules tu rentres tu le prends
un coup de massue gomez derrière les
oreilles et je me suis réfugiée dans les
bras de ma petite puce
oui c'est toute l'histoire qu'est ce tu
fais toi tu nous fais professeur choron
un arrimage sa tantine journal alors y
avoir alors alors tu vois il a emballé
comme ça je l'aimerais ouais parce que
deux dont il ya jet et le préservatif
musicale pas bon alors tu vois bon il
est enveloppé la gt-r laboratoire qui
m'a offert 120000 capot est moi j'ai
ajouté une petite musique à l'élastique
alors si tu veux j'en ai j'avais monté
un sens à vous faire la démonstration
alors tu vois une fois que c'est monté
sur la tute ecclésiastiques
1 tu souffles dedans
ça fait rire les femmes ces longues
années ça les détend on est donc tu
laisses moi l'assassin tu économises des
disques de la jeune fille s'est mise ou
whisky des disques et du temps à la tête
du feu alors je suis très fier parce que
déjà c'est un journal qui porte mon lot
bah ouais ils ont depuis longtemps
professeur choron il faudrait alors il
fallait que ça vienne un jeune arrive à
la vie lance-t-il euros lavail à eddy
mitchell sur une page enfin talent est
grand comme minima ta jean marie gourio
qui fait 22 points et tissot génial
génial enfin c'est sans fin est vraiment
petit format et coûter combien 25 francs
prix des billets à prix d'ami prix
gagner 25 entre les pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
il m'était impossible ou